is log X which is the log caveat before
and I've got one over X right like I'm
considering this and the product of
something and the reciprocal of
something okay I generally find that Oh
what like you know how I said addition
is easier than subtraction
well multiplications like a hundred
times easier than division so let's have
a go at this now I'm easy things first
I've drawn this left head branch of one
over X but of course it doesn't matter
because because it's outside the domain
of log X right so since I don't have
both of them it really doesn't matter I
can ignore that okay now the second
thing I notice is both of these grammars
both of these graphs do not exist at x
equals 0 ok now I wasn't gonna make a
big deal out of this but I've got a
great question before which highlight in
fact I should make a big deal out of it
I just have a hollow circle here right
because it doesn't exist it's outside
the domain of log X right but I'm not
gonna put a hollow circle on this breath
in fact I'm going to put an asymptote
now the question is how do I know that
this one has an asymptote but this one
just has a hollow circle they don't have
crack yeah okay it does it does approach
you've got this one approaching the y
axis there you go this one approaching
the y axis so there's clue number one
both of these are asymptotic to x equals
0 so therefore it's reasonable to assume
the whole thing is okay but there's
another more critical reason ok very
good
it's all about the ordinance okay so let
me try to explain this unpack it for you
right um
no sorry come back over here when you
see something like we've seen functions
like this we see these four agents right
and you kind of just been used to
thinking up it does it exist therefore
there should be a vertical asymptote
there okay but that's not the conclusion
you should always draw okay
these are vertical asymptotes at say x
equals zero and the reason why is
because exactly agenting what the
ordinates are doing if x equals zero I
can't go there do you think about what
happens when you get very close to x
equals zero right now when you get very
very close like say
x equals whatever a million or whatever
a billion billion or something like that
then this denominator getting very small
makes the whole thing get huge right
tiny tiny joão means the whole thing is
big right that's that climbing that
asymptotic behavior you're used to right
you're going to go okay I'm gonna push
to one side and then of course when
you're getting to negative small values
you approach negative you okay but
there's no such thing happening here
right as X just gets closer and closer
to zero there's no there's no climbing
off to a positive or negative infinity
he just gets small and then stops
existing right so this doesn't give you
an asymptote because you're multiplying
this gives you an asymptote because
you're dividing right and we're very
little numbers on the denominator that's
what they do
very good so I've got that piece that's
nice are there any other easy value so I
can get out of that I'm looking for
roots right because if either of these
have roots then the whole thing should
have raised right so that's why a log X
has an intercept so therefore 0 times
something should be 0 okay you're right
with that so I've got that that's an
easy point okay now what's happening on
the outsides and this is quite hard okay
for instance here's something I could do
um I'm guessing on coming towards the
essence right here and that's easy I
know that positive times negative will
be negative so I know I'm down here but
question am I am I going to be above the
log curve and going towards the acetone
or am I going to be below the log curve
and going towards the asymptote it's not
immediately obvious which one it is
because they're both approaching the
asymptote okay now just think for a
second before we jump out in the mid Sun
okay there is actually enough
information on here to tell me where
there are below log X or above log X and
again it has to do with the ordinance
the question is which ornaments for
after it gives you
okay all right
your logic is so very very close it's
very very close in fact if the opposite
let me try show you one side okay I'm
sorry you are very close he's on the
right track now figure these guys right
it's all that the Ordnance right and I
let me try and make this a little bit
easier for you and just do the visuals
okay right here I'm at one right now I'm
thinking about what's happening to the
left look to the left what are the
ordinates like I'm a bigger or smaller
than one
Enza they are bigger that's what you
meant to say okay now when you're
multiplying by a bigger number I've got
like some negative out of here right
well when I multiply that negative
values by a number bigger than 1 it gets
more negative do you see that
like for example er at x equals a hug
I'm gonna be a 2 right
so if I'm it to here I multiplied by
some number down here I'll be twice as
negative right so it's more it's more
negative its lower does that make sense
so it's going to be at this point it's
gonna be steeper okay so in fact I'm
getting this guy it's pretty hard to
draw it accurately because you've
probably got your locker already quite
steep but your composite has to be
steeper okay now I wonder if therefore
you can draw a conclusion for me on the
basis of the argument just made I said
look I've got the log curve and I'm
multiplied by numbers bigger than 1 so
it gets more negative more whatever it
was what's happening to the right of one
is getting NOLA guys like less than one
so that means that point okay yes the
answer is yes I didn't draw my
conclusion that way I'll see if I
because I'm I make it really obvious to
you if that did not seem as obvious to
me okay let me try to explain the way I
enlarged account and came to the same
conclusion over here
and once my by big numbers alright so
that's why it gets more negative but in
here I passed a threshold this is what
Rath was talking about now all of these
numbers all the ordinates to the right
of here they're like you know this one
and then there's 9/10 and then there's
7/8 and then they all they're all
getting smaller right so therefore these
numbers when I multiply them will make
them less than the marker does that mean
they should all be smaller so I'm
getting this kind of behavior okay now
then comes the next question right if
I'm under the log curve do I stand the
water just kind of grown like will not
curve grows slowly right and increased
seriously does this guy just grow super
super slowly or does he turn it and come
back to the axis now how can you work
out which one it is okay if you had a
different chain log functions you could
differentiate okay and you could find
what the new moon is doing and that
would work and it will work eventually
but we have better tools that we have
access to or I should say simpler ones
firstly before we could have a hard way
let's go to the easy way okay um you
have this thing in your bag which is
really really good at dealing with big
numbers right and that's why like try to
work out what happens over here right
like what it makes one hundred or a
thousand or a million okay now what you
put in here tonight log a thousand
divided by a thousand right I've gotten
you so you can check it out you'll get
very very quickly well you want to go
check it out
what kind of is he getting yeah you're
getting super tiny numbers like you'll
get close to zero and you're getting
close pretty quick smart so you're gonna
get this kind of behavior its asymptotic
to y equals zero okay now okay so then
the question becomes like but why is it
just because this guy's coming to a zero
well let me ask you this let me ask you
this if I asked you to have just just
humor me for a second right if I ask you
to graph this right and you think oh
I'll just do the components right I've
got X cubed and then I've got one over X
and look this guy's approaching zero
that so the whole thing should approach
zero right
well no because of this guy right now
what you've got here and this is the
crucial bit on what you understand is
you have this interplay between someone
who's increasing and someone who's
decreasing so the question is who's
pulling harder right is the log curve
increasing faster then one of them the
hyperbola is decreasing which one is
going faster it is a really easy way to
show you which one wins okay let's stick
out whatever X okay whatever it looks
like this now if you multiply whatever X
by X just those straight on linear
function you guys know what happens when
you multiply X by 1 over X right what do
you get you just get a horizontal line
do you agree with that you get this guy
so what I take that to mean even though
it doesn't look like it is that whatever
X and X this is increasing this was
decreasing and they are pulling at
exactly the same rate does that make
sense
one's increasing at exactly the same
rate that the other is decreasing which
is why when you put them together you
get a net change of zero
they're just like locked in a tug-of-war
you okay with that all right now I think
about 1 over X and compare it to log X
now tell me for he
and here which one's pulling harder the
linear function after I get past here
right the linear function is pull
apart-er do you agree right and it has
to pull that hard to make it even out
well what's that what curve doing
he pulls harder for a little while and
then he just like gives up he just gets
tired he slows down right do you see
that
so therefore if these guys are exactly
locked and this guy is weaker than this
guy then clearly one of her ex is going
to pull her off does that make sense
he's decreasing faster than log X is
increasing does that make sense
do you see the visual argument that I
made okay it's almost like you're
putting things on a scale if these guys
are equivalent and this guy's worse well
this guy a winner right so that's why
I'm decreasing and that's how you can
make this argument that you're hitting
down okay later on you'll learn how to
differentiate and you'll find that
stationary point you'll say well it's a
max you can determine it quite easily
okay yep so if I continued my log curve
right I saw my hyperbola remember how he
said all of these hyperbolas there are
fractions small fractions I should take
proper fractions so that's why I'm
always underneath this locker but at the
same way this log curve right it's
always bigger than one you see that
like I sorry it's gonna it's always
going to pass one and it's never gonna
come back okay so therefore you're
always going to be above the hyperbola
you're always going to be between them
okay but I know now based on this
argument that it's going to drop to one
of the acid
I talked about this before if I'm
approaching zero and one over X is
approaching zero I might understand a
person's Europe right like they've birth
asymptotic to zero so therefore I don't
need to put in an extra curve while I
make a more compact